♪ ♪
>> TIME NOW FOR "ONE MORE
THING."
RUSH LIMBAUGH MADE A VERY
SURPRISE ANNOUNCEMENT ON HIS
RADIO PROGRAM TODAY AND HE TOLD
HIS LISTENERS THAT HE’S JUST
BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH ADVANCED
LUNG CANCER.
LISTEN.
>> MY INTENTION IS TO COME HERE
EVERY DAY I CAN.
I’VE HAD SO MUCH SUPPORT FROM
FAMILY AND FRIENDS DURING THIS
THAT IT’S -- IT’S BEEN
TREMENDOUS.
>> AND OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
GO OUT.
HE SAID HE’S GOING TO BE TAKING
A FEW DAYS OFF DURING THE TIMES
WHEN HE’S GOING TO BE UNDERGOING
TREATMENT, BUT NOT EVERY DAY.
HE’LL BE ON AND OFF FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS, SO HOWEVER LONG IT
TAKES TO GET BETTER.
AND WE WISH RUSH THE BEST.
>> I CAN THINK OF ANYBODY WHO’S
BEEN A BIGGER INFLUENCE IN
CONSERVATIVE THOUGHT IN THE TYPE
OF PERSON WHO WAS ABLE TO BRIDGE
THE INTELLECTUAL RIGHT OF
BUCKLEY TO THE COMMON MAN.
I REMEMBER WHEN IT STARTED IN
THE ’80s, NOTHING LIKE IT,
LATE ’80s.
THERE’S NOTHING LIKE THEM, IT’S
A PHENOMENON.
>> HE REALLY IS.
KATIE.
>> GIANT -- I WAS GOING TO SAY
IS A GIANT, AS DANA JUST SAID,
HE’S BEEN A PIONEER AND HE’S
NEVER BACKED DOWN FROM A FIGHT,
SO I WISH THEM WELL AND I HOPE
THAT HIS TREATMENT IS
SUCCESSFUL.
>> YES, SPEEDY RECOVERY.
>> HE’S HAD SUCH AN IN-DEPTH
KNOWLEDGE OF HISTORY, A SPEECH
ONE TIME WHEN HE GOT AN AWARD
AND IT WAS JUST AMAZING, ALL THE
THINGS THAT HE KNEW HOW MUCH HE
TRULY LOVES AMERICA AND IT
TRANSFERRED TO HIS LISTENERS AND
HIS VIEWERS.
>> AND I JUST WANT TO SAY COME
SOMETIMES RUSH AND I HAD BIG
DIFFERENCES, BUT RUSH WAS ALWAYS
SO KIND.
I THINK SOMETIMES HIS
HUMANITY -- IN A MOMENT LIKE
THIS, RUSH, I WANT YOU TO KNOW